there's a lot of um social pressure
actually yeah
to immediately laugh off any conspiracy
theory if it's done by the the bad guys
right you will quickly get mocked and
laughed at and not taken seriously if
you give any Credence you know back the
lab leak was it was a good one where
it's like uh turned out that that was at
least very credible if not true and
that was a perfect example of one where
when it first came out and not only so
so Brett Weinstein talked about it and
then I in a totally different
conversation said something
complimentary about him on a totally
different subject
and people were saying Tim you might
have gone a little off the deep end
you're like quoting someone who is like
a lab leak person so I was getting my
reputation dinged
for complimenting on a different topic
someone whose reputation was totally
sullied because they had you know they
questioned an Orthodoxy right so it's
you see in so what does that make me
want to do distance myself from Brett
Weinstein that's the at least that's the
incentive that's uh and what does that
make other people want to do don't
become the next Brett Weinstein don't
say it out loud because you don't want
to become someone that no one wants to
compliment anymore right you can see the
social pressure and that's and of course
when there is a conspiracy that social
pressure is its best friend
because then they see the people from
outside are seeing that social pressure
enact like a Tim Urban becoming more and
more and more extreme to the other side
and so they're going to take the more
and more and more extreme I mean this
what what do you see that the pandemic
did
that kova did to our civilization in
that regard in the forces why was it so
divisive do you understand that
yeah so covert I you know I thought
might be you know we always you know the
ultimate example of the topic that will
unite us all is the alien attack yeah
although honestly I don't even have that
much Faith then I think there'd be like
some people are super like you know
pro-alien and some people aren't the
alien but anyway I was actually Sergeant
to interrupt because I was talking to a
few
um astronomers and they they're the
first
folks that
maybe kind of sad in that if we discover
Life on Mars for example
that there's going to be potentially a
division over that too where half the
people will not believe that's real
well because
we we live in a current Society where
the political divide
has subsumed everything and that's not
always like that
it goes into stages like that we're in a
really bad one where it's I actually in
the the book I call it like a Vortex
like a like a like a almost like a
Whirlpool that pulls everything into it
it pulls it pulls um and so normally
you'd say okay you know immigration
naturally going to be contentious that's
always political right yeah but like
covid seemed like oh that's one of those
that will unite us all let's fight this
not human virus thing like obvious is no
no insensitive no one's like getting
hurt when we insult the virus like let's
all be we have this threat it's common
threat it's a threat to everyone of
every nationality in every country every
ethnicity and
and what it didn't do that at all the
whirlpool was too powerful so it pulled
covet in and suddenly masks
if you're on the left you like them if
you're on the right you hate them and
suddenly lockdowns if you're on the left
you like them and on the right you hate
them and vaccines this is people forget
this when when they Trump first started
talking about the vaccine
Biden Harris
Cuomo they're all saying I'm not taking
that vaccine not from this CDC because I
was too rushed or something like that
but because I'm not trusting anything
that Trump says Trump wants me to take
it I'm not taking it I'm not taking it
from this CDC so
this was if Trump this Trump was almost
out of office but at the time if Trump
had been it would have been I'm pretty
sure it would have stayed Wright likes
vaccines the left flood doesn't like
vaccines instead the president switched
and all those people are suddenly saying
they were actually specifically saying
that if you you know that that like if
if you're saying the CDC is not
trustworthy that's misinformation which
is exactly what they were saying about
the other CDC and they were saying it
because they genuinely didn't trust
Trump which is fair but now when other
people don't trust divide in CDC
Suddenly It's this kind of
misinformation that needs to be censored
so it was a sad moment because it was a
couple months at the very even a week or
so the I mean a month or so at the very
beginning when
it felt like a lot of our other
squabbles were kind of like oh I feel
like they're kind of irrelevant right
now yeah and then very quickly the
whirlpool sucked it in and and
and in a way where I think it damaged
the reputation of these a lot of the the
Trust In A lot of these institutions for
the long run but there's also an
individual psychological impact it's
like a vicious negative feedback cycle
where they were deeply affected on an
emotional level and people just were not
their best selves
that's definitely true yeah I mean
talk about the Primitive mind I mean
what one thing that we've been dealing
with for our whole human history is
pathogens yeah and it's it's emotional
right it it brings out you know there's
really interesting studies where like
if
they they studied the the the the
phenomenon of disgust which is one of
these like
you know smiling is universal you don't
have to ever translate a smile right
certain you know you know throwing your
hands up when you're when your sports
team wins it's Universal because it's
part of our we're coding and so is
disgust to kind of make this like you
know face where you wrinkle up your nose
and you kind of put out your tongue and
maybe even gag that's to expel expel
whatever's because it's It's the
reaction when something is potentially a
pathogen that might harm us right feces
vomit whatever
but they did this interesting study
where people
who in in two two groups the control
group you know was shown images of
um and I might be getting two studies
mixed up but they were showing they were
showing images of like car crashes and
like disturbing but not disgusting and
the other one was showing like you know
like you know rotting things and just
things that were disgusting and then
they were asked about immigration these
were Canadians and the group that was
had the disgust feeling going pulsing
through their body was way more likely
to prefer like immigrants from White
countries
and the group that was had been shown
car accidents they were they still
preferred the groups from White
countries but much less so and so what
what does that mean it's because with
the disgust impulse makes us scared of
you know sexual practices that are
foreign of ethnicities that are not look
that don't look like us of of it's still
xenophobia so it's ugly it's this really
ugly stuff this is of course also how
you know the the Nazi propaganda with
cockroaches and uh or it was uh Rwandan
was cockroaches you know the Nazis was
rats and you know
it's it's specifically it's a
dehumanizing emotion so
anyway we were we were we were talking
about
um covid but I think it does it Taps
deep into like the human psyche in it
and it's I don't think it brings out our
I think like you said I think it brings
out an ugly side in US